I'm an MIT professor but I do not design
buildings or computer systems rather I
build body parts palenik legs that
augment human walking and running in
1982 I was in a mountain climbing
accident and both of my legs had to be
amputated due to tissue damage from
frostbite here he can see my legs 24
sensors 6 microprocessors and muscle
tendon like actuators I'm basically a
bunch of nuts and bolts from the knee
down with his advanced Bionic technology
I can skip dance and run thank you I'm a
banach man but I'm not yet a cyborg when
I think about moving my legs neural
signals from my central nervous system
pass through my nerves and activate
muscles within my residual limbs
artificial electrodes sense these
signals and small computers on the
Bionic limb decode my nerve pulses into
my intended movement patterns stated
simply when I think about moving that
command is communicated to the synthetic
part of my body
however those computers can't input
information into my nervous system when
I touch and move my synthetic limbs I do
not experience normal touch and movement
sensations if I were a cyborg and could
feel my legs
via small computers inputting
information into my nervous system it
would fundamentally change I believe my
relationship to my synthetic body today
I can't feel my legs and because that my
legs are separate tools from my mind in
my body they're not part of me I believe
that if I were a cyborg I could feel my
legs
they would become part of me part of
self at MIT were thinking about neural
and body does
in this design process the designer
designs human flesh and bone the
biological body itself along with
synthetics to enhance the bi-directional
communication between the nervous system
in the built world neuron body design is
a methodology to create cyborg function
in this design process designers
contemplate a future in which technology
no longer comprises separate lifeless
tools for reminds in our bodies a future
in which technology has been carefully
integrated within our nature a world in
which what is biological and what is not
what is human and what is not what is
nature and what is not will be forever
blurred that future will provide
humanity new bodies neural and body
design will extend our nervous systems
into the synthetic world and the
synthetic world into us fundamentally
changing who we are by designing the
biological body to better communicate
with the built design world humanity
will end disability in this 21st century
and establish the scientific and
technological basis for human
augmentation extending human capability
beyond innate physiological levels
cognitively emotionally and physically
there are many ways in which to build
new bodies across scale from the
biomolecular to the scale of tissues and
organs today I want to talk about one
area of neural and body design in which
the body's tissues are manipulated and
sculpted using surgical and regenerative
processes the current amputation
paradigm hasn't changed fundamentally
since the u.s. Civil War and has grown
obsolete in light of dramatic
advancements and actuators control
systems and neural interfacing
technologies a major deficiency is the
lack of dynamic muscle interactions for
control and proprioception
what is proprioception
when you flex your ankle muscles in
front of the Galang contract
simultaneously stretching muscles in the
back of your leg the opposite happens
when you extend your ankle here are
muscles in the back of your leg contract
stretching muscles in the front when
these muscles flex and extend biological
sensors within the muscle tendons send
information through nerves to the brain
this is how we're able to feel where our
feet are without seeing them with their
eyes
the current amputation paradigm breaks
these dynamic muscle relationships and
in so doing eliminates normal
proprioceptive sensations consequently a
standard artificial limb cannot feedback
information into the nervous system
about where the prosthesis is in space
the patient therefore cannot sense and
feel the positions and movements of the
prosthetic joint without seeing it with
their eyes my legs were amputated using
this civil war-era methodology I can
feel my feet I can feel them right now
as a phantom awareness but when I try to
move them I cannot it feels like they're
stuck inside rigid ski boots to solve
these problems at MIT we invented the
agonist antagonist smile neural
interface or Amy for short the Amy is a
method to connect nerves within the
residual to an external Bionic
prosthesis how is the Amy design and how
does it work the ne comprises two
muscles that are surgically connected an
agonist linked to an antagonist when the
agonist contracts upon electrical
activation it stretches the antagonist
this muscle dynamic interaction causes
biological sensors within the muscle
tendon to send information through the
nerve to the central nervous system
relating information on the muscle
tendons length speed and force this is
how muscle tendon proprioception works
and it's the primary way we as humans
can feel and sense the positions
movements and forces on our limbs when a
limb is amputated the surgeon connects
these opposing muscles within the
residual to create an a knee now
multiple Amy constructs can be created
for the control and sensation of
multiple prosthetic joints
artificial lecturers are then placed on
each ami muscles and small computers
within the Bionic limb decode those
signals to control powerful motors on
the banach limb when the Bionic limb
moves the ami muscles move back and
forth sending signals through the nerve
to the brain enabling a person wearing
the prosthesis to experience natural
sensations of positions and movements of
the prosthesis can these tissue design
principles be used in an actual human
being a few years ago my good friend Jim
Ewing of 34 years reached out to me for
help Jim was in a terrible climbing
accident he fell 50 feet in the Cayman
Islands when his rope failed to catch
him hitting the ground surface he
suffered many many injuries punctured
lungs and many broken bones
after his accident he dreamed of
returning to his chosen sport of
mountain climbing but how might this be
possible
the answer was team cyborg a team of
surgeons scientists and engineers
assembled at MIT to rebuild Jim back to
his former climbing prowess team member
dr. Matthew cardi amputated Jim's badly
damaged leg at Brigham Women's Hospital
in Boston using the Amy surgical
procedure tendon pulleys were created
and attached to Jim's tibia bone to
reconnect the opposing muscles the Amy
procedure re-established the neural link
between Jim's ankle foot muscles in his
brain when Jim moves his phantom limb
the reconnected muscles move in dynamic
pairs causing signals to pass through
nerves of proprioception to the brain so
Jim experiences normal sensations of
ankle foot positions and movements even
when blindfolded here's Jim at the MIT
laboratory after his surgeries we
electrically linked Jim's ami muscles
via the electrodes to a banach limb and
Jim quickly learned how to move the
banach limb in four distinct ankle foot
movement directions we were excited by
these results but then Jim stood up and
what occurred was truly remarkable
all the natural biomechanics mediated by
the central nerve
system emerged via the synthetic limb as
an involuntary reflexive action all the
intricacies of foot placement
thank you during stair ascent emerge
before our eyes
here's Jen descending steps reaching
with his bionic toe to the next stair
tread automatically exhibiting natural
motions without him even trying to move
his limp because Jin's central nervous
system is receiving the proprioceptive
signals it knows exactly how to control
the synthetic limb in a natural way now
Jim moves and behaves as if the
synthetic limb is part of him for
example one day in lab he accidentally
stepped on a roll of electrical tape now
what do you do and something's stuck to
your shoe you don't reach down like this
it's way too awkward
instead you shake it off and that's
exactly what Jim did after being
narrowly connected to the limb for just
a few hours what was most interesting to
me is what Jim was telling us he was
experiencing
he said the robot became part of me the
morning after the first time I was
attached to the robot my daughter came
downstairs and asked me how it felt to
be a cyborg and my answer was that I
didn't feel like a cyborg I I felt like
I had my leg and it wasn't that I was
attached to the robot so much as the
robot was attached to me and the robot
became part of me it became my leg
pretty quickly thank you
by connecting gyms nervous system
bi-directionally to a synthetic limb
neurological embodiment was achieved I
hypothesized that because gym can think
and move his synthetic limb and because
he can feel those movements within his
nervous system the prosthesis is no
longer a separate tool but an integral
part of gym an integral part of his body
because of this neurological embodiment
Jim doesn't feel like a cyborg he feels
like he just has his leg back that he
has his body back now I'm often asked
when I'm gonna be neroli linked to my
synthetic limbs bi-directionally when
I'm gonna become a cyborg
the truth is I'm hesitant to become a
cyborg before my legs were amputated I
was a terrible student
I got DS and often F since school and
then after my limbs are amputated I
suddenly became an MIT professor now I'm
worried that once I'm neroli connected
to my limbs once again my brain will
remap back to its not-so-bright self but
you know what that's okay because at MIT
already have tenure
I believe the reach of neural body
design will extend far beyond limb
replacement and will carry humanity into
realms that fundamentally redefine human
potential in this 21st century designers
will extend the nervous system into
powerfully strong access skeletons that
human control and feel with their minds
muscles within the body can be
reconfigured for the control of powerful
motors and to feel and sense exoskeletal
movements augmenting humans strength
jumping height and running speed in this
21st century I believe humans will
become superheroes humans may also
extend their bodies into non
anthropomorphic structures such as wings
controlling and feeling each wing
movement within the nervous system
Leonardo da Vinci said when once you
have tasted flight you will forever walk
the earth with your eyes turned skyward
for there you have been and there you
will always longed to return during the
twilight years of the century I believe
humans will be unrecognizable and
morphology and dynamics from what we are
today humanity will take flight and soar
Jim Ewing fell to earth and was badly
broken but his eyes turned skyward where
he always longed to return after his
accident he not only dreamed to walk
again but also to return to his chosen
sport of mountain climbing at MIT teams
cyborg built Jim a specialized limb for
the vertical world a brain-controlled
leg with full position and movement
sensations using this technology Jim
returned to the Cayman Islands the site
of his accident rebuilt as a cyborg to
climb skyward once again
[Applause]
thank you ladies and gentlemen Jim Ewing
the first cyborg rock climber
[Applause]
[Music]